voilà plutôt puisque c'est le deuxième
épisode le deuxième pré-draft hall après
oklahoma city direction lyndiane à un
spécial pays serge vous avez été très
nombreux à nous regarder la dernière
fois on parlait du pic 2 est bien une
diana ils ont pique 6 0 6 2 31 et le 60
soit dit en passant d'ailleurs c'est pas
le 67 58 parce que miami et milwaukee
ont perdu leur choix de second tour on
vous le rappelle on va surtout parler du
choix numéro 6 ici dpi soeur c'est le
principe des traits draft talk on a pris
deux buts de la drass et à chaque fois
on fait un live dédié à la franchise
avec trois intervenants d'abord un
manque des médias et ce soir c'est made
in karsenti comment vas-tu melvin falu à
laax merci merci de cette invitation
sha1 un rider assidus d'envergure
puisque je suis pas énormément la n6 est
donc ravi d'être à la coupe ryder et
journaliste basé aux états unis
il fait très beau basée à san francisco
le temps est au beau fixe pour les voir
également dans les pommes
et jus tu bosses notamment avec
basketusa et tu contribues aux podcasts
émissions
âge qui est
une émission qui monte côté côté analyse
basket à chaque fois est évidemment dans
ces rapts on aura aussi un membre de la
communauté des fans la parole du peuple
et ce soir c'est marne qui va bien
office de porte voix du peuple peters de
la playlist nation salut ma salut merci
pour l'habitation en tout cas est pareil
je suis pas un immense fan siège je vais
essayer de lui mettre ses premiers mais
du coup évidemment on suit tous les
articles lubbock draft avec grand
plaisir il ya été tué hier sa mort il ya
absolument aucun problème pourquoi y ait
aucun problème parce qu'il ya eu ce
qu'elle a pour ça qu'ils aient car il ya
des cassettes de n 6 et dans ses
placards et qui on regarde de l'année et
d'autres prospects d'ailleurs puisqu'on
va peut-être parler de prospector ncs
soir
donc une commande à tu as mis ton beau
maillot de l'adico
exactement on a représenté 2 tant bien
que mal et les couleurs d'épaisseur n'a
cherché quelque chose au fond de
l'armoire pour déterrer est en train
laurie marque adepte de chicago et un
match plus utile on a trouvé un victor
oladipo qui passait par là donc c'était
l'occasion c'est pas mal gamal noman
paysage
très belle référence alors pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas là pour le premier live on
va rappeler le principe
première partie on fait un constat c'est
quoi les pays seraient aujourd'hui où on
en est où ils vont vingt points sur le
roster l'identité qui se dégage de cette
équipe les problèmes qui a aussi dans le
jeu etc et en deuxième partie on va
essayer de faire coller les prospects
peuvent être disponibles vers numéro 6
alors on n'est pas devant nous on va
faire un peu en fonction de ce qui sort
à droite et à gauche
et les insérer dans cette identité seuil
est de voir à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler avec intel dans le roster
l'année prochaine qu'est ce que ça va
apporter au jeu qu'est ce que ça
pourrait apporter aux jeux d'eau etc
voilà ces deux parties est évidemment
tout au long de ce live et qui en
prendra vos questions dans le chat pour
pour tenter de répondre à vos questions
même vos remarques vous pouvez débattre
aussi a vu beaucoup de beaucoup de
débats pendant le premier là le chat
était très animé donc voila c'était
super super tu t'es battu mais je suis
petit je regardais ça du coin de l'oeil
je surveillais non juste de règles dans
le chat on est poli et et en arguments
de ses idées
c'est tout ce qu'on va demander pour
pour ce soir
messieurs je crois qu'il est l'heure de
commencer
l'état des lieux de ses erreurs
et là on va peut-être faire un point
déjà sur les forces en présence parce
que c'est une des équipes qui a eu le
plus de line-up utiliser une dernière à
cause des trails
donc le roster il ressemble à quoi alors
je vais
en attendant que je partage mon écran
marins pour toi quels sont les joueurs
on va dire le coeur nucléaire sur lequel
il faut compter pour les une deux trois
années à venir du côté digne anne
au québec qu'à mandats on est en pleine
reconstruction on va pas jouer le titre
l'an prochain sauf miracle mais c'est
peu probable
bon clairement la pièce la plus
importante du roster ou là qu'il ya
quelques mois pour moi en tout cas c'est
tyrese halliburton donc c'est le nouveau
nouveau patron en tout cas à lui de le
devenir
j'ai tendance à appeler le jeune prince
donc on va dire le jeune prince pour les
animaux
il ya toujours maïs turner qui mine de
rien même si ce sera sa dernière saison
n'est pas si âgé que ça jusqu'ici ce
même si on attend beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus de lui chaque année il est
toujours là reste à savoir s'il sera
toujours là les années à venir la crise
vaart est aussi la bonne surprise
voilà un petit pyromane qui il est là
pour longtemps a priori tout de même
alors c'est très récemment donc a priori
est là pour rester tout comme les aléas
jackson aussi qui fait partie selon moi
en tout cas des des bonnes pièces autour
desquels il faudra construire un petit à
petit fric bien athlétique voilà comment
on peut comme on peut apprécier qui qui
déborde d'énergie et on a quand même
quelques joueurs assez sérieux aussi
comme dj mc connell qu'on a prolongé
même s'il était blessé le tout cas
saison et beaucoup d'interrogations
ensuite pour la suite damman il ya au
chef du set on peut citer que j'aime
beaucoup dwan washington junior au site
hérité leur mais là on est plus sur des
joueurs d'orientation va dire c'est pas
déposer des mangues et façon des joueurs
indispensables n'ont pas dire tu sais ça
c'est ça et je n'ai pas cité michael
brooks dunn et betty hilde parce que
pour moi c'est ce sont avant tout des
assets ce n'est pas au point de vue mais
mais voilà à priori en tout cas en tout
cas il ya beaucoup de rumeurs ont
notamment autour de mâle comme brooke
donne c'est peut-être je suis peut-être
peut-être un petit peu méchant avec lui
on reviendra on y reviendra mais mais
voilà a priori légale enis toujours moi
habitions dans le chatt jaden smith et
en est
presque
quotidiens warren thiviers warren il va
faire quoi
voilà c'est une colle bien aux arènes
mon avis ça va finir pas à mon avis à
mon avis tu témoignes ça va voir dans
quel état il est mais à mon avis ça
pourra plus aider un prétendant au titre
que l'épaisseur moi j'ai du mal à le
voir rester dans cette équipe surtout vu
le dû
construire quoi bon mais à voir ok et
jaden smith
et ricky rubio pareil les voix les voit
pas réussi
kallen smith il me semble qu'il y à il
ya un problème au niveau du contrat
cette fois que l'épaisseur ce que vous
lui peuvent lui offrir que 4 millions de
dollars quelque chose comme ça il me
semble t'il d'année prochaine donc à mon
avis juste par rapport à ça ça va être
compliqué de me garder après lecture ou
bio
lecture ou bio en fait d'un vétéran pour
portables sallibartan perso j'aime bien
mais après faut voir quand il pourrait
revenir et
à quel prix mais mais dans l'idée je
pense pour port faveur de mentor à
halliburton j'aime beaucoup alors on
sait qu'il ya un cap minimum en biais
que l'épaisseur ce pour l'instant sont
en dessous il faut il faut qu'ils
dépensent au moins 19 millions de plus
que la masse salariale qui pour
l'instant prévu donc peut-être ça va
être pour béquilles
ou qui sait jamais mais sinon ils vont
être sanctionnés donc ça sert à rien de
bison de l'espace exemple des caps space
prendre un gros contrat on va dire après
ça peut être aussi un move on en parlera
plus tard mais un manque de drap de
prendre un très gros contrat bien chiant
d'une autre équipe
pour avoir des ascètes qui viennent avec
pour compléter voilà vous avez le visuel
la bienvenue à tous et bienvenue à toi
gros nounours
on a aussi des two way is que nous on a
un petit on est un petit coeur tant pour
les twins avec avec notamment nike inc
qui est un bon joueur c'était un bon
joueur n 6 et voilà un gros défenseur
potentiel les belles soeurs se
compteraient du bon du bon travail en
repérant aussi certains certains joueurs
ces derniers temps tu parlais de douane
washington terry taylor marin c'est des
joueurs qu'on n'attendait pas forcément
alors certes il était dans une équipe
qui tourne qui était plus se tourner
vers le temps thing qu'autre chose mais
qu'on vraiment apporter juste et hérité
lors par exemple c'est une vraie bonne
surprise en toucher deux mots
moi c'est clair bah disons que
l'épaisseur vos problèmes depuis
quelques années maintenant ça traîne
notamment au niveau du rebond et du dieu
seul un petit peu en défense et hérité
lors il est là faire le entre guillemets
le sale boulot il apporte vraiment
quelque chose et c'est vrai que le peu
de temps de jeu qu'il a pu avoir
finalement assez conséquent et tous les
blessures et le temps king de fin
d'année on va dire
et honnêtement dès qu'on le voit sur sur
les parcs m il a pas vraiment quelque
chose j'aime beaucoup ce joueur pour le
coup il fait vraiment plaisir à voir jeu
j'aime bien il a fait des matches tous à
plus de 20 rebonds
mais c'était déjà une machine à statte
bizarre en civière mais qui tournait à
énormément de rebond alors qu'il est à
hugues est ce que tu as un truc qui
vient à l'esprit quand tu vois cette
fiche récapitulative d'épaisseur ah
c'est pas beau mais
après c'était intéressant et puis ça
n'empêche pas cool s4 s5 l'épaisseur
c'est qu'ils ont une équipe avait déjà
beaucoup de joueurs solides avec
beaucoup de mecs qui sont destinés à
être all players avec un plancher assez
c'est assez fiable même dans leur
contrat rookie tu disais crises du genre
d'écriture t'écoutera oki mais est-ce
qu'il n'est pas quasiment plus vieux que
miles turner on est franchement doit pas
être très très très loin donc notamment
de l'avoir assez safe avec tu arte avec
jackson qui ne machine effectivement
athlétique avec halliburton donc un
trait maintenant il en faut alors il va
falloir ramener un gros talent et pour
rebondir sur les tourelles ou j'aime
beaucoup ce que finn diana sur le rhône
dans leur processus de recrutement ils
ont essayé beaucoup de joueurs ils ont
essayé beaucoup de règles étoiles sont
allées chercher
ramon squattait georgia ils ont associé
des jours comme ça plein de petits
soldats des robots nord comme vous
l'avez dit il on fait plein de mx ils
ont coupé des touristes n'ont repris et
il arrive à en faire le charles guérin à
les développer donc là dessus il ya un
vrai staff intelligente j'ai
l'impression chez les placers
très bon résumé maintenant on va se
demander quelles sont les forces et déjà
une question avant avant de parler du
jeune marin et melvin pour vous c'est
quoi l'identité de jeu des pays sauf
pour vous est ce qu'il ya une identité
qui se dégage de cette équipe
actuellement pour moi il ya
jamais on n'a pas tout simplement parce
que c'est très compliqué de juger sur
sur cette saison première saison sourit
carlyle menée par les blessures miné par
voilà un gros traders plein milieu de la
saison donc c'est vraiment difficile on
est sur une année où voilà ça visait
clairement le le temps king et les
belles défaites au mieux donc c'est
vraiment très difficile de ce long
moment en tout cas trouvé une véritable
adn autant voilà sous frank vogl ya
quelques années il y avait quelque chose
même si on est macmillan et pourtant
dieu sait que je le détestais y avait
quand même quelque chose mais mais voilà
là c'est très compliqué selon mans en
tout cas de trouver l'adn avec tous et
tous et line up différente où tous ses
blessures difficiles jusqu'ici en tout
cas je vois melvin qui acquiescent
ouais bah ouais non je pense et ça avant
d'avoir une identité je pense qu'il faut
avoir une certaine stabilité comme tu
disais j'ai regardé les chiffres 37,5 de
départ différent c'est la troisième plus
grande nombre en nba cette saison près
de 400 matches ratés sur blessure
donc je pense qu'il ya il faut de la
stabilité pour pouvoir mettre en place
une fondation collective et puis après
il faut une sorte de ligne directrice et
tu vois on voit on le voit dans les
play-offs rebond avec les plus jeunes
l'équipe je regarde par exemple memphis
il ya une identité de jeu qui est clair
et il ya une fondation et tout le monde
peut dans cette direction là aujourd'hui
à mon avis ils ont la chance d'avoir
teracent halliburton donc est ce que tu
peux construire autour de lui et le
mettre dans un dans un système qui va
vraiment maximiser ses forces en attaque
et après
après je pense que le plus gros problème
ce niveau la défense c'était quoi
l'avant-dernière défense au niveau des
défensives brytting l'évaluation des
fanci de cette saison je pense que la
dila l'identité défensive c'était on a
mal turner on essaie de renvoyer tout
sur ma liste en heure un peu à l'image
du jazz avec rudy gobert le problème
c'est qu'ils sont pires que le jazz au
niveau 2 au niveau de la défense en un
contre un m donc donc je pense que là il
va falloir il va falloir beaucoup
beaucoup de boulot est vraiment avoir un
schéma défensif maxime qui peut limiter
la casse mais je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais au niveau des joueurs qui
sont présents dans le roster là est-ce
que vous en voyez qui peuvent relever ce
défi défensif en particulier extérieur
ou est-ce que ça va venir avec avec des
signatures de free agent mettrait
alors une crise due arte pour parler de
lui le plus récemment drafté c'est un
joueur qui est potentiellement un
défenseur corps n est pas un winch
stoppeur ce soit mais c'est un bon
défenseur voilà c'est un défenseur
collectif est vraiment très intéressant
avec un parcours universitaire complet
du côté doré bon on aime bien parler
défenseur intelligent toujours de
classer les bonnes rotations c'est un
mec qui sait que latéralement il faut
pas tenir tout le monde du coup ils
donnent une direction ils envoient du
bon côté donc c'est un jour qui fera
toujours le les bons choix et quand tu
parlais de défenseurs sur les postes
extérieurs sur le point taf attaque
maintenant on dit beaucoup
carisa lipton et un peu là dedans aussi
c'est que c'est pas le plus gros
athlètes c'est pas la plus grosse
mobilité latéral mais il sait quel genre
fois on est à gauche quel enfant n'a
droite sur quatre joueurs faut que je
passe en dessous quelques jours je passe
au dessus donc ça peut être une bonne
base de reconstruction en tout cas des
joueurs intelligents même s'il manque un
gros axe capteurs ou tu peux très bien
dit
puisqu'on est sur la décence
marrant ça défend des plutôt comment sur
les pick and roll est ce qu on était sur
des schémas variés ce qu'on était plus
sûr du drop comme disait mais limite
d'âge ou principalement droit ben
c'était savoie ont nettement c'est un
très bon résumé c'était voilà on amène
tout sur maïs turner qui reste encore un
très très bon rhume protecteur mais ce
n'est pas du niveau de rudy gobert et
les efforts collectifs étaient
clairement pas présent donc notamment
quand on demande à sabonis était encore
là parce qu'on voit là on le loue
suffisamment sur ses grandes qualités
offensives mais bon de l'autre côté du
terrain c'était très compliqué pour
rester poli donc à partir de là bas mais
si on ne peut pas tout faire encore plus
quand il est blessé la moitié de la
saison et à partir de là voilà avant
dernière défense de la ligue je veux
dire c'est compliqué laissez ça se
ressentait clairement voilà maintenant
on ne peut pas tout faire il y en a un
grand et un réel besoin de deux défenses
physique dur sur l'homme et ne pas lui
laisser tout seul on ne galère en fitr
voilà ce que ce que disent les deux
trois stades que j'avais relevé
l'équipe qui a le pire pourcentage de
trois points contre elle donc ça veut
dire que voilà des trop de trop de
shoots ouverts en face ou alors des
shoots ouverts pour les mauvais joueurs
en fassent don qui fait pas forcément
peut-être les bons choix défensif
puisque en plus c'est l'équipe qui est
quatrième en terme de trois points
tentés contre elle ça fait tout ça fait
beaucoup de points quand même si tu es
le meilleur pour cent le pire pour s'en
faire le meilleur pourcentage pour
l'adversaire est le quatrième meilleur
nombre de trois points tente et ça fait
beaucoup
et puis des problèmes à relever sur son
bas sur le pick and roll c'est bien de
parler puisque son dernier en points
concédés par possession que ce soit le
rôle man qui ternit où que ce soit le
bol en leurs pick and roll qui termine
donc c'est vraiment un très très gros
problème et là on peut se demander
s'il n'ya pas besoin melvin
d'avoir vraiment de l'impact physique on
a parlé de défenseur intelligent sur les
sur les arrières ailiers s qui a pas
besoin vraiment de un peu une bête
physique quoi on ne sait pas un gain un
gars qui met de l'intensité tout de
suite sur le bal
si je pense que je pense je pense que si
alors je vois dans le chat qui accords
bino ce qui nous qui dit que sa tâche
est bel et bien dans ce rôle de soldat
défensif est ce que vous pensez qu'il a
cette capacité physique dans l'impact et
peut-être d'être un peu j'ai envie de
dire le celui qui donne le ton de la
défense avec avec mike turner si vous
pensez qu'il peut jouer ce rôle là où
est-ce que c'est plus quelqu'un qui doit
qui doit qui doivent recruter que ce
soit je suis passé à la brasse ou ou
gala freed une sim par trade
pour pour moi il manque de régularité
j'adore le joueur aussi et c'est souvent
un facteur x dès qu'il va faire un bon
match tout l'équipe autour de lui sera
bien meilleure mais voilà toujours des
petites hésitations des petites fautes
un peu idiotes donc ça me fait sortir du
match assez rapidement
je pense qu'il faudrait que le plan
cadre et à ce niveau là il ya du
potentiel maintenant est ce que ça peut
être vraiment le le soldat côtés de mike
turner je l'espère mais je suis pas
encore convaincu j'ai personnellement
on se projette déjà un petit peu mais
est ce que il ya dans cette draft dans
le pré du top 10 des joueurs qui peuvent
hormis cetto m'bengue qui sera plus la
rente 6e
vraiment un pas créer une défense très
très fort dès leur première année une
première le deuxième n'a pas mal on a
pas mal alors après c'est toujours la
question du potentiel et du plancher je
veux aller on va reparler il y en a sur
les extérieurs voilà peut-être tenez le
nom directement des débriefings qui
devrait pouvoir être disponible à ce
moment là bas grave qui est un joueur
avec un
un potentiel défensif
vraiment hyper intéressante
je lui pose plus intérieur vous avez un
joueur comme djendjen effectivement que
je vois dans le job qui peut être une
option avec un pivot très athlétique
vraiment pour contraire qu'il ya un
manque de maturité pour le moment et
puis ça dépendra aussi de qui reste et
qui bouge et sinon vous avez des joueurs
avec un moment haut potentiel moi je
serais pas allé chercher ici mais où où
il y un peu partout que certaines
certaine mode prévoit dégâts
moi je suis pas fan de la défense de
tziganes mais l'om il est projeté la
gauche avec badji jérémy soran voilà sur
des postes de ford qui pourrait avoir
une mission défensive en première année
très rapidement
voilà donc une large palette mais de
l'antre la mise en défensive et le fait
d'avoir un impact tout de suite toute
façon c'est très grave
quand tu regardes les chiffres à la fin
de l'été saison rookie même quand ils
ont l'air d'avoir fait une très bonne
saison rookie c'est très rare qu'un
impact très positif défensif r john
cette année qu'une anomalie complète
evans gobelet pareil
vraiment des cas très particuliers quoi
même même même un joueur comme scotty
barnes il faudrait que je
me suis quasiment sûr qu'il n'y a pas vu
d'impact au niveau statistiques prouvent
et de son art de son apport défensif
alors qu'il est guère mon défenseur mais
edward exception de façon dans le basket
ont tu peux attaquer tout seul tu
défends à 5 donc si ton équipe elle est
pourrie défensivement ce sont souvent
les équipes du top de la draft c'est
très compliqué de pouvoir te montrer
individuellement là dessus parce que
trois ans de marasme collectif kindia
n'a pourrait être l'année prochaine
absolument nous allons nous allons tout
doucement nous diriger alors déjà
offensivement à quoi ça ressemblait à la
fin de saison parce que j'ai sorti des
stats mais vu que ça a changé en cours
de saison elles sont moins parlante
quand même melvin elle tournait autour
de quoi cette attaque
j'imagine du pick and roll halliburton
ouais ouais moi je vais me reposer de
fonds marins pour un portail à des
bêtises mais j'imagine que nous on a
essayé de donner la balle à halliburton
après je pense que
marin le disais en introduction par le
mal comme brandon qui va sûrement être
utilisés puisque comme on a sept
pourrait attirer d'autres joueurs je
pense qu'il faut vraiment lui donner la
balle et donner la carte blanche choix
de laisser le laisser jouer le ciel
mettre en place il ya une qualité de
passe qui est exceptionnel pour son
pourcentage à une capacité à vraiment
manipuler le pick-and-roll défense déjà
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment lui
mettre la balle dans les mains et marin
qui moi si ce n'était pas le cas lors de
ces lors de ses 25 derniers matchs
depuis qu'il est à depuis l'arrivée
c'était c'était totalement ça s'est
baladé burton est
pas débrouille toi mais bon on n'était
pas très loin ses
voix sur la fin de saison pour moi c'est
elle aussi beaucoup du quasiment du
héros ball mais qui vise la défaite en
fait donc c'était
particulier c'est vrai que kankan
sabonis était encore là bon bah voilà
c'était totalement différent beaucoup de
geopost et
voilà c'était pas du tout le même le
même rythme aussi notamment en attaque
mais dans la fin de saison c'était voilà
ce que je peux faire en termes de passe
mes coéquipiers il arrive à terminer
l'action ou pas et voilà bon courage
pour les saisons à venir
[Musique]
comment ça s'appelle le héros bol quand
c'est pour perdre les matches du coup
de pouce en pole sur les
ordis sur sur les stats alors à prendre
avec des pincettes puisque effectivement
sabonis partie en cours de saison et
que j'ai trouvé intéressant bonne
présence au rebond offensif
le tout sans concéder trop d'occasions
de transition donc c'est à dire que
souvent du jeu dépossession c'est un
truc à la mode ces derniers mois nba
l'épaisseur s'en sortent au moins bien
là dessus c'est à dire qu'ils vont ils
sont non seulement efficace sur les
coups de bach mais en plus ils prennent
beaucoup de rebonds offensifs donc voilà
c'est peut-être dû de l'influencé
kelly taylor dont on parlait tout à
l'heure il à jackson qui est aussi un
bon nettoyeur cours côté romand francis
donc vous voilà des jeux et une
efficacité correct sur pick'n roll aussi
à noter on est dans cette identité là de
jouer beaucoup de pick and roll de 60 et
de jouer très peu de 10o il n'y a pas de
joueurs pour jouer biseau il n'y a pas
de joueurs pros stop il ya quasiment pas
part peut-être duarte qui pourrait faire
ça de jouer aux screen des binômes des
choses des choses dans le genre donc
donc céder c'est une équipe qui joue sur
ses forces ne connais pas beaucoup si je
devais résumer
c'est bien dit
non mais je veux dire c'est pas comme si
le mal vers
benghazi pendant que j'allais dire comme
je le disais en plus c'est que si tu
tues encaisse énormément tirs à trois
points et que derrière tu peux pas
vraiment en maths que l'on voit alors on
voit à l'extrême avec les mots avec les
mavs dans ces play-offs mais si tu peux
vite a du mal dans ce dans ce secteur de
jeu ça va être ça m'a couché pour toi
comme tu dis ça inquiète pas beaucoup de
bien pour l'instant pas beaucoup de
a beaucoup de forces en présence
donc on va voir comment ça va comment ça
va évoluer mais je pense qu'il ya un
vrai besoin au niveau 1 déjà dit au
niveau des ailes
et après de trouver cette immensité
comment confectionner basketball qu'est
ce que ça veut dire aujourd'hui je sais
pas alors donne 7 on nous dit beaucoup
de pays sur la fin d'année en tout cas
sur les stats sur la saison ça se voit
pas du tout mais sur la fin de l'année
je confirme marins ça allait plus vite
plus de transit ou de du jeu vers
l'avant
oui cure avancés tels obstacles la roue
libre de fin de saison rapide passe
flashy comme j'ai pu voir l'an dans le
chat s'était clairement ça c'était voilà
ça allait un peu à cent à l'heure quitte
à être totalement brouillon en attaque
avec des poules up à trois points deux
buts deux aides alors qu'il reste vingt
secondes de possession mais aller vite
active
dont j'ai dans le texte ça pour nous
amener
tout ça pour nous amener à cette
question
qu'elle ose ofi asset draft puisque là
on est au peak 6 en plus donc où il peut
se passer plein de choses aux pics il
peut se passer plein plein de choses
déjà au big 4 il ne pouvoir se passer
plein de choses nos petites 6 on salue
nos amis des kings mais aupic 6
c'est pas évident ça peut partir dans
plein de directions en tout cas
même nous on regarde plein de matches on
aurait du mal à savoir quoi faire donc
donc melville pour toi c'est quoi la
philosophie
l'ondraf un gros talent peu importe son
poste londres ap qu'un joueur
qui est capable de
combler un besoin pour le moment et on
va de toute façon autant qu est une
année pour aller au à la draft 2000 23
mois à première vue je me dis s'il ya un
ailier caduc avant la potentielle en six
jeux je vais dans cette direction là
pour avoir un sens dax halliburton cet
ailier là potentiellement mike stoller à
l'intérieur et patata vraiment une sorte
de de bakbone sur laquelle tu peux
construire après vu la situation dans la
coalition c'est vrai que je me posais la
question aussi de est-ce que tu prends
le meilleur joueur disponible à cette
position peu importe la position on a vu
que ça a marché pour les pour les cartes
par exemple mais l'année dernière donc
je pense c'est une question que d'une
question que pour pour hugues est ce que
tu penses qu sicilia il ya il y aurait
potentiellement un ailier qui peut avoir
ce genre de ce genre d'impact ou est-ce
que tu serais plus toi dans un meilleur
joueur disponible
alors moi j'ai ma réponse perso c'est de
dire que tu prends le meilleur talent
disponible quand il donne mais j'ai la
question et on va peut-être se renvoyer
des balles de ping pong c'est de savoir
qu'est ce que veut faire un tonneau l'an
dernier dont 1 sur l'autre ils y
prennent figure t il recrute un coach
comme rick carlisle qui est pas dans un
développement de jeunes est ce qu'ils
veulent gagner des matchs très
rapidement et prendre un mec
il se disant bon en indiana et nous il
faut qu'on remplisse la salle parce
qu'ils n'y a plus d'essence pour le
tracteur ou est-ce qu'on est sur un
joueur ouais je suis désolé je suis
désolé pas fait assez c'est facile c'est
pas de retenue
jamais jamais ou bien est-ce qu'on est
sur une brève reconstruction et dans ce
cas là on se dit malcom braff donne ça
peut partir contre le pic de new york vu
que c'était un truc qu'on voit beaucoup
milestone heures ça peut partir contre
de la scène où on prend vraiment un
énorme talent jeunes et on est dans une
vraie reconstruction et dans ce cas là
effectivement tu me d'alexis turc on
enchaîne mais j'ai des joueurs - cf avec
beaucoup plus de potentialités notamment
de créativité en main ce qui manque
malheureusement indiana
marins dans les déclarations de gm staff
comment tu le sens est ce que tu sens la
reconstruction excusant landi de
toujours gagner des matches parce que
indiana moi j'ai jamais connu indiana
tank et
jamais m
historiquement indian tant que peur mais
mais là clairement il selon moi vraiment
des changements même au niveau des
déclarations que ce soit de kevin
pritchard même aussi de rick carlisle
qui cac a bondi au caire construction ça
nous on peut passer par là ça me dérange
pas donc pour moi partir de là c'est
pareil ça va être une draft pour moi
faut miser sur le plus gros talent
disponible en 10 ans potentiellement sur
une grosse connerie bon bah big thing
faut que ça tombe sur eux désolé mais
avec potentiellement voilà le bon j'ai
des noms en tête je vais pas si c'est
trop tôt mais
pour savoir si par miracle on a failli
donncha ou jay denney heavy disponible
en 6 et ben faut foncer il faut pas se
poser de questions
et surtout pas
surtout pas miser sur un qui gagnent
murray parce que je vais je les ai vus
voilà je les ai vus récemment un petit
peu dans les rumeurs ça ne fait pas très
honnêtement ça ne fait pas
une
quel est selon toi
mais donc tiède paulo jabbari soit parti
ouais
probable pas sûr
derrière eux qui sont les meilleurs
talents disponibles selon toi dans cette
grave
chez dunlop effectivement capables de
créer de l'espace capable de créer du
tir hyper athlétique on a vu très très
peu mais il ya il ya un réel fantasme
qui peut qui peut qui peut aboutir et
qui comblerait des des besoins sur le
long terme qu'ils ne donneraient à vélo
des n'a besoin jadona il est l'enfant du
pays un qui fait sa fac a perdu où la
maman qui souhaite y reste là bas et
c'est donc lui gosse de diana et tous
excellents créateur arrière incombe aux
flammes avec maryse halliburton dans
tout le monde de fantasmes
capable lui aussi peut-être peut-être un
initiateur principal sur le jour le sud
de san carrière et on en parlait tout à
l'heure et jerry finn qui est peut-être
le sixième homme cité et dont la cote
est un peu blessant cependant
qu'ils aient hui pour le coup est un
joueur sous indice à seyssel je pense
qu'ils attirent et quasiment 40%
entreprenant plein de situations qui a
toujours pris le mur extérieur défensif
mais qui a un historique de blessure
majeure au niveau niveau du bas du corps
qui peut peut-être refroidir et
de haendel et de bust pour pouvoir
justement crêpes à la main et si je peux
me permettre une petite gourmandise
monde en moins dit que mon personnel et
tu sais bien qu'il faut qu'on parle de
ce jour là
moi j'ai mis un certain mais qui
s'appelle deron simone dans mon top 10
et qui est un créateur fou et qui est un
pari on le disait sur notre chemin de
comparer de saab soit tu le prends top
10 soit une draft pas et qui est a créé
un terreau balle en main qui ne peut pas
tirer mais qui va payer 2 mètres et qui
peut aller plus vite que tout un pari
complètement fou pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas c'est le seul joueur qui peut créer
balle en main d'après à peu près du top
10 mondial de la draft le seul joueur
qui peut initier tout ce qui est fait le
fait le coup folie je l'espère c'est un
joueur qui a marqué pas mal de points en
nba comme mbaye qui a fait remonter sa
cote qui était assez basses il il a
scoré avec efficacité son coéquipier ce
mix a également scoré mais avec moins
d'efficacité des rentes simone
effectivement un profil de joueur qui va
vers le cercle il y en a c'est peut-être
le seul contexte qu'elle ou il peut
avoir un peu des ballons des
30 mais même ça a été une lutte est ce
que tu voudras francis alors que tu peux
peut-être la voir en 31
c'est ça la question c'est pas question
ça c'est une autre question voilà les
les talents disponibles alors vers qui
sur qui vous avez des questions marin et
melvin on va on va regarder filer un
petit peu les les prospères bas rhin
pour essayer de les imaginer dans
l'effectif pays sort ce
mois j'ai une question pour le groupe
avant de partir là dessus parce que on a
parlé vite fait de kevin pritchard a
parlé de rick carlisle
ma première question est ce que ricard
est le coach qu'il faut pour cette
équipe parce que bon ce qui est dit dans
la presse c'est une chose mais j'ai du
mal à voir un rick carlisle quand même
ok avec une reconstruction
et deuxième question à ce que avec
pritchard qui est quand même quand même
un peu de pression sur cette draft est
ce qu'on pourrait voir l'épaisseur
essayer de trade up pour rentrer dans le
top 5 dans le top 4 dans le top 3 pour
aller récupérer un
une des valeurs sûres de cette draft
à propos de rick carlisle j'avoue que
c'est difficile parce que là on passe on
a enchaîné trois coachs en trois saisons
net macmillan
je vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet n'est
de bürglen ça ressemble plus à un pari
raté et voirie car là il connaît déjà la
maison ça reste un coacheur super
expérimenté pour moi c'est un bien plus
grand donc
une bonne partie des gauches qu'on a pu
avoir maintenant pour une reconstruction
c'est vrai qu'il ya ces déclarations
dans la presse et ce qu'il en est
réellement
là c'est difficile à dire
et pour en revenir sur le potentiel
trade up j'en rêve voilà maintenant est
ce que est ce que ce sera réalisable est
ce qu'on peut pas lâcher le pixi c'est
maicon brogden à
la sacramento mais bon est-ce qu'ils en
auront vraiment besoin
oui c'est clair qu'on tend vers quoi ça
crame et ouais sacramento alors c'est
par excellence et le pigeon facile quand
on aime bien déconner comme sa maison de
vaux 10e qui a l'air un peu plus
intéressant alors il fait une raffinerie
un peu contesté mais ils égalisent
analytics
mal comme brandon problème c'est que le
dossier médical fait pas rêver que le
contrat est esquivée que c'est des
joueurs assez délicate première équipe
c'est pas un poste arrière qui va les
intéresser mike stone dans lé reste une
dernière année de contrat moi je trouve
que ça ne sont pas suffisants j'irai
plus facilement je pense chercher un
deuxième
choix au premier tour peut-être dans le
top 15
soit avec new york soit avec washington
tout de même au nord de gestion plein
délit et c'est plutôt que c'est rise up
ça me semble malheureusement pour voix
c'est réaliste
logan logan
hugh est ce que c'est pas moi j'ai
toujours dit que cette draft elle était
elle n'avait pas un talent qui pouvaient
changer une franchise ou alors il est
bien cachée des bidons
est ce que ça vaut le coup du trade up
dans ses draps est ce que ça vaut le
coup il ya une vraie plus value de
lâcher un michael braun juste au passé
de 6
si tu veux un créateur
si tu as un mec qui peut changer le jeu
peut-être que oui peut-être que wes y
derrière par étapes aucun créateur et
que cette équipe c'est vraiment son
besoin principal donc s'ils veulent
[ __ ] à poil en dix ans et nous il nous
faut absolument un mec qui peut faire un
écart sur sur voile assure une isolation
et tout pourquoi pas mais je te dis pour
moi je vois pas pour faire le listing ni
orlando lâche un pic en fins et je pense
que c'est hors de question
ok s'ils sont là les était 6e c'est pas
pour revenir sim cette année
comment dire houston est en
reconstruction aussi voudront un des top
3 et sacramento une amie carrière en
cinquième position à qui on n'a
ni de voir un sac detroit voilà district
imposture aussi ça me semble peu
crédible franchement
donc doazit melvin je pense que il ya
pas d un peu de portes ouvertes nous
sommes sans même parler du personnel qui
est la côte et prospère une bonne et on
voit quand même année après un exercice
assez difficile de d'échanger son pic
dans le top 10 dans le quinze de la drac
ou
non de face je suis assez d'accord je
vous demandais juste il s'il est si
l'épaisseur agente pas de nom pas de
coup de foudre au cices s'ils sont
capables de faire quelque chose pour
récupérer avec quelque chose d'autre
mais
à voir
après en ce qui concerne les justement
parlant des joueurs qui peuvent être
être dispo je sais pas si tu peux nous
remettre la liste alex ouais
c'est de l'art mais
dis moi
merci
alors tu parlais de way auprès des
drinks
fns que
ouais moi j'aimerais en savoir un peu
plus j'ai eu la chance de le voir jouer
en live quand ils sont passés à san
francisco la lors d'une audience aux non
initiés
j'avais été un peu déçu mais bon après
ça sur un match donc j'ai pas envie de
partir sur des
ou de me faire confiance et analystes
j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir où ce que
vous voyez dans joueurs et qu'est ce
qu'il peut apporter à nyala alors
juste pour vous là vous avez des stades
je vous aimez les films qui
effectivement numéro 6 sur notre big
board je remonte un tout petit peu on a
actualisé les mensurations de mètres 0-1
de 13 dans dr pas dur
91 kg mais mais 91 kg solide quoi
c'est vraiment des gros segment gros
tronc à la place des cuisses et tous et
il est assez impressionnant
adrienne jean luc déjà drainé griffin
avant de parler de son potentiel plafond
aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être le meilleur shooteur la
draft
moi même c'est un jeu un shooter cas
montré qu'ils pouvaient tirer dans
plusieurs styles de deux tiers on a bien
souvent par les 400 shooter en fin de
chaîne pas de problème pour lui c'est un
joueur qui peut sortir des écrans serait
axé vite s'équilibrer un tir rapide un
tiers à distance nba a mais qui a aussi
genre un peu très peu de séquences mais
poser quelques écrans évolué en pick and
pop donc pourquoi pas pour lui faire ça
j'aime bien le fait que chez le joueur
si on garde la la chaude charte c'est si
vous le trouvez qu'ils aient pas de
latéralisation tir c'est à dire que la
balle arrêtée à gauche la balle arrive
magogois arrive ma droite il déclenche
de la même manière il n'y a pas trop de
temps pour repasser sur la main forte et
étirés et en plus de ça c'est un joueur
dont le tir va être respectée donc il
aura des gens qui manquent la zone et
qui peut dans ce cas là exploser des
clauzades à coudre avec des belles
qualités athlétiques donc le seul truc
qu'on lui reproche finalement à tougan
plus fine c'est peut-être que moi comme
là je vois sur le scouting les potes de
steve in the deep run est un problème
tu as d'explosivité sur le premier pas
dans le dribble qui on ne sait pas s'il
pourra y remédier avec avec du temps
avec la récupération de sa blessure
quand même qui a été destructrice pour
lui dans son développement physique au
niveau lycéens
c'est ça
c'est plus bas fait l'enjeu de son
scouting report est ce que puisque si
les bas pour continuer là-dessus s'il
n'est pas apte à initier à au moins
aller au cert et c
est ce qui peut valoir le coup quand
même en 6 si c'est juste
un swing dit pour l'instant l'adie est
en construction mais il ya un vrai
potentiel
je pense je pense que oui je pense que
oui parce que tout le monde ne peut pas
porter la balle en nba et que le joueur
a l'air d'être lucide sur ce qui s'est
fait reste qui sait pas faire j'aurais
l'air d'accepter de partager
le ballon alors qu'il a été toute sa
carrière j'ai une carrière lycéenne la
star numéro un c'était le prospect
numéro un de sa classe de draft avant sa
grosse blessure donc c'est un mec qui
concerne son rôle qui cautionnent ces
forces et quitte apportera tous les
soirs du tir du cut de la collectivité
et de la défense donc c'est juste que
j'aime pas le foot ndjana parce qu'ils
ont trop car de chrtr mais partout sinon
je pleurais prendre top 6 e sacramento
un catch pour y aller facilement
quand tu te dis qu'en temps quand vous
dites qu'il va pas qu'il n'a peut-être
pas le cercle est ce que ces mêmes par
exemple en deuxième jamais dire en
deuxième rideau aussi d'un pick and roll
entre halliburton et de turner tu swing
de l'autre côté est ce qu il peut
attaquer les clauses out ou est-ce que
même ça fait un peu fameux faire
compliqué non ça peut le faire
pacifiquement avec sophie tu voulais
répondre mais ça il peut le faire en
fait c'est juste que le manque de
premier pas est problématique le dribble
il ya peu de changements de direction il
ya peu de changements de rythme de
changement de vitesse donc un mec voilà
core i7 ligne de fond ou qu'il ya un
renversement facile oui ça il pourra y
aller et là quand même la puissance pour
encaisser du contact même si il n'a pas
trop panier parce que je pense qu'il a
peur de se reblesser nettement et qui
l'aï mis du temps à se mettre au rythme
à quoi tu joues qui sortait du banc etc
mais mais ça peut être un axe de
développement pour lui sachant que 64%
de cette séance au dessus d'une passe
décisive près du cercle la queue dans
40% des cas quand même il a réussi à se
créer son accès au panier meilleur jeu
sur un pivot lui malheureusement
mais on voit donc vous voyez sur la
charte de
de gauche sur votre écran un joueur qui
a été efficace dans de nombreux secteurs
comme il le disait tout au long tout
autour de l'arc à trois points
qui a duré in the sea et qui a été
efficace ce même cercle alors jorat
remettre dans le contexte d'une équipe
de duke était dominante et qui donc
était efficace elle aussi en globalité
marin toi ton chouchou c'est plus jayden
ivy
clairement pas je m'en cache pas depuis
quelques mois maintenant pour moi le
destin voulait qui tombe à indiana
malheureusement les boules de kim jong
un ont probablement décidé autrement
non clairement c'est le backcourt
faisait rêver avec halliburton et 20 un
côté vraiment 7h heure que peu de
joueurs ont du côté bas déjà peu de
joueurs ont toutes qualités là
globalement mais alors c'est encore plus
vrai du côté des pays ça se voit selon
moi c'est un petit peu trop statique oui
voilà c'est pas et viennent vitesse
d'accélération totalement folle enfin
voilà vraiment le pack course à ne
serait-ce que le bac courte avec
halliburton faisait feu en faisant
fantasmer plus d'un je pense et les gens
voulaient clairement partie mais bon
c'est quand en 6e ça me semble
falloir voilà alors prié fort espérer un
miracle mais c'est pas le choix de
jeu ça me paraissent plus que j'espère
j'espère fin mai mais je plutôt d'accord
avec les griffin c'est un peu le choix
de le choix de la raison contre le choix
du coeur je tenai vicois globalement
walajah de nagui huguet donc on a parlé
de ses qualités mais il ya peut-être des
gens qu'ils connaissent pas aussi dans
de l'eau chat
les gens qui écoutent qui nous
écouteront
commence comment on l'insère dans le jeu
indiana qui à forte dose de pick and
roll pour halliburton quand même
majorité
qu'est ce que lui va faire pendant ce
temps à l'opposé du ballon et ce qui
peut poser des pics à halliburton est ce
que ça peut poser problème de faire ça
est-ce que halliburton peu spotter
pendant que lui va gérer des possessions
demi terrain comme comment tu vois
l'impact d'un jedi sur une équipe qui
l'avantagent pour cette projection là
c'est koné vient de donner vie du côté
de produire ou non qui jouait pour les
boilermakers dans la big town où il a
joué très souvent il a évolué très
souvent loin du ballon parce qu'il y
avait un collectif que c'était bien gül
et que tu avais des vétérans seniors que
tu avais un pivot qui était un très bon
passeur donc c'est un joueur qui on a
déjà vu beaucoup évolué loin du ballon
moi j'ai aucun problème à voir
halliburton qui porte le ballon pour
plusieurs séquences et joe donnelly qui
sort des écrans parce qu'il l'a
énormément fait pour diot des sorties de
floppy est très axé dans l'action sera
axée donc vers le cercle pour tirer il
le fait très bien il a montré que c'est
un joueur qui pouvait que tu es ex
qualités athlétiques finir par dessus
tout montré aucun problème ça pas de
souci et puis halliburton a très souvent
joué avec un porteur de balle qui
monopolisaient le ballon dia one shot
mais il a joué avant iowa state avec un
porteur de balle comme moi c'est à
bolton qui comptait le ballon à steam ou
essais avec des porteurs de balle qui
pourraient ballon d'eau c'est un tir
hors tellement fort que patronat dessus
c'est un contexte vraiment je pense
l'idéal où tu peux développer ton joueur
pour les points faibles parce que c'est
pas c'est pas un joueur parfait john
hayes vie on a vu que c'était un mec qui
allait très vite et parfois qu'elle est
trop vite qui avait encore de la
jeunesse que ce n'était pas un meneur de
jeu à proprement parler de naturel avec
un moment parfois des visions sur
plusieurs renversements tout ce qui est
pas simple pour les lectures et les
lectures de jeu et surtout surtout c'est
un joueur qui a du mal à se créer son
écart d'entre 2 c'est un mec parce qu'on
parle de créateurs en main de tout à
l'heure on dit ça mais qui a pris très
peu de tout le pas trois points qui a
passé des bacs à passer cette step là
qui a très peu de poulpe à mi distance
notamment sur pick'n roll et c'est une
vraie faiblesse et pour boucler sur le
dossier alors du combat n'est plus le
voir en interview avec marc schmitz où
on analyser le jeu et que c'était en
direct pendant les matchs des jeunes et
lui là dessus il est très très cohérent
il dit mon gros défaut s'est créé de
l'écart à mi distance pour créer mon
propre retire il faut que je travaille
ça sera sûrement flotteurs c'est ça que
doit développer pour devenir un vrai
créateur ballaman primaire c'est un
joueur qui est déjà consciente il
faiblesse qui a pas peur de les exposer
et qui posent dessus ça c'est vraiment
positif
effectivement
j'avais ma mère je reviens
ça y est fait mais chut
marin
est ce que dans dans l'idée
défensivement pour toi il est plus
important d'avoir quelqu'un dont on est
porteur de balle quelqu'un qui s'insère
dans cette scène historique
d'intelligence collective quand on
parlait tout à l'heure avec halliburton
duarte et pourrait être le début d'une
identité ou pour parlais tout à l'heure
c'est difficile à avoir une identité une
identité de joueurs célèbres au
bas pour moi il ya déjà un bon un bon
noyau de joueurs voilà de cela des role
player ou même thérèse halliburton qui
conclut basket de très bons voire
assez c'est assez exceptionnel on va
dire donc pour moi il faudrait vraiment
des défenseurs dur sur l'homme pas
forcément dans le dans une défense plus
collective et et voilà non vraiment
plutôt première option d'assez loin
personnellement
j'en profite aussi parce que là on
vantait les mérites de jay denney vicky
qui avait conscience de ce qu'il fallait
améliorer il ya un côté bien côté leader
aussi qu'il ferait énormément de bien à
cette équipe et c'est vrai qu'on vende
beaucoup alcon groupe donne un jour très
cérébral aussi et je pense ça reste un
super volet avec
avec rick carlisle par exemple
maintenant faudrait je pense aussi un
joueur capable de tuer toutes les
troupes et je suis pas persuadé que
malcom braff donne et je suis pas aussi
persuadé pour l'instant que tyrese
halliburton soit fois dans cette optique
là mais voilà jade et naïve juste
parfait
il faut j'étais naïve yodelice et c'est
un truc bien qu'on n'a pas parlé mais
qui est important dans la construction
d'une équipe
psychologiquement il faut plusieurs
profils et peut-être qui manque au 6e
seguin peu alpha et indiana ce qui
attire les autres pas par la parole par
les actes parfois mais par la parole
ouais je pense que moi je verrais bien
halliburton rentrer dans ce rôle là mais
plus sur la durée je pense qu'il faut
qu'il le qui le développe broc donne je
pense que alors oui l intelligence de
jeu comme tu le disais marin il ya
peut-être la relation avec avec avec
rick carlisle problème c'est que ce
n'était pas sur le terrain avec des
blessés et 50 % des matches ça me font
pitié d'être d'être un leader janvier
qui a fait plus de la même chose avec
avec miles turner qui pourrait servir de
leader en tant que vraiment pièce
maîtresse de cette défense mais pareil
c'était pas sur le terrain c'est
compliqué de c'est compliqué de faire ça
donc
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il faut
quelqu'un alors
je vais prendre le jeu faire le
parallèle avec l'équipe que je connais
de mieux c'est-à-dire les warriors on a
d'un côté un curry qui est pas quelqu un
qui est forcément extrêmement vocale
mais par contre si je pense que c'est
quand même un alpha la façon dont il
joue et de la façon dont il s'y montre
l'exemple et je pense que halliburton
peut être cette personne qui est un peu
qui rassemble autour de lui c'est
quelqu'un qui joue avec avec tellement
d'enthousiasmé je pense que les joueurs
adorent jouer avec lui de part parce
qu'ils essaient 2 2 m de mettre tout le
monde tout le monde en confiance par sa
qualité de passe
donc pour pour l'épaisseur ce qui peut
être entre guillemets c'est des gros
limitons dream green c'est à dire le mec
qui va gueuler qui va mettre qui va qui
va aussi bavarde ans de pouvoir un peu
essayé de essayer de rentrer un peu dans
mes dents les gars pour que tout le
monde se mette se mettent à défendre que
tout montre amen intensité c'est vrai
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui quand on
regarde le roster
c'est un peu ça un peu savent quoi alors
une proposition une imposition alex tu
vis dans le futur parce que tu as réussi
à trouver une page d'un joueur en
anticipation de ce que melvin est le
dire avant même que le professionnalisme
dumex l'incroyable
tahri ism ma proposition vous la
proposition notamment de belles qu'il a
figuré vous sixième sur son big board
donc très très haut plus haut que agency
tard il isole à quoi ça ressemble hugues
on a à la fois quelqu'un qui peut
apporter défensivement en année 1 mais
qui peut qui a le potentiel pour
apporter peut-être plus houda
tard wilson sais
c'est le joueur de basket moderne dans
le corps c'est un cas un ailier qui
montrent qu'il est déjà l'hyperpuissance
hyper développé qui est capable de
défendre plein de postes
c'est un joueur pour le coup on
demandait de là un peu de folie un peu
de grosses bouge bon bah tu as peut-être
la plus grosse grande gueule de tout là
toute la cuvée
c'est un malade mental tu as oui et
c'est peut-être la plus grosse question
sur sur le joueur sait que le basketteur
laisse qu'ils le corps c'est un corps de
top 10 de draft sans aucun problème il
est comparé dans son corps en corps de
patrick williams comme sur les dernières
années qui était de quatre là dessus
mais le mental c'est un joueur avant
d'aller sur le jeu qui n'a il a elle
connu de programmes universitaires qui
sont ce qu'ils sont et les soucis
médecine en terme de coaching c'est pas
exceptionnel et dans les deux programmes
universitaires il a jamais écoutés le
coach il a toujours fait ce qu'il
voulait sur le terrain il a toujours
refusé toutes les consignes bon je sais
pas c'est écrit cas là et ça passerait
par contre effectivement tellement du
talent et amène delà de la folie à
indiana ce que ce que l'épaisseur non
pas du tout
marin est ce que est ce que
diana c'est quand même pas l'équipe qui
pourraient cadre est un mec un peu fou
justement est-ce que les gens quand ils
arrivent dans l'indiana y sont pas un
peu plus calme
il ya moins de distractions donc a
priori
voilà je crois que je pense qu'on est
obligé de se calmer mais maintenant
c'est vrai qu'un joueur comme glenn
stevens own à ces moments de folie a
connu ses moments de folie et pour le
coup je pense qu'encore aujourd'hui
c'est le joueur le le plus apprécié de
tous tous les fans
et d'assez loin un
petit côté des bears a en tout cas je
pense mais après c'est peut-être pas le
même type de folie j'avoue que je ne
connais pas du tout harrison je me suis
pas je m'étais pas renseigné je pense ça
peut être un bon environnement pour
cadrer de toute façon voilà encore une
fois c'est pas l'endroit qui fait le
plus rêver voilà je pense pas que trente
six mille boîtes de nuit de strip club
où je ne sais quoi d'autre donc à partir
de là je pense qu'il
faut avoir cette ambition de folie à la
baisse j'imagine en tout cas
que starbreeze bazille lazy wave
j'allais dire qu'on fera qu'on a pas
parlé de l'âne stevenson quand on a
quand on parlait de tout début 2002
chaudes et des joueurs potentiels alors
évidemment c'est pas quelqu'un sur
lequel tu va construire la nouvelle
fondation la nouvelle identité mais
est-ce qu'il peut justement aider en
tant que vétéran pour peut-être cadres
et des jeunes
maintenant qu'il est mort y est toujours
un peu fou fou mais je pense que il a
quand même cette expérience qui peut
être qui peut être intéressante on a
vraiment l'impression qu'il est qu'il
est à la maison uniquement quand il est
à indiana quoi c'est ça il retrouve ses
qualités de ce kit boulistique
uniquement et souvent uniquement à
domicile d'ailleurs ce qui est que voilà
ce que généralement les matches à
l'extérieur on ne voit plus du tout
c'est assez catastrophique
maintenant est ce que ça peut être un
leader vocal
je ne sais pas honnêtement j'ai un grand
doute il ya un côté voilà il ya une côte
et folie mais en terme de qualité de jeu
un tracé que voilà c'est on est loin
d'un vrai mode green c'est clair je j'ai
une insulte ben 10 ans a donc
je sais pas je sais même pas s'il a la
maturité nécessaire très honnêtement est
vraiment j'adore ce joueur mais je
miserais pas le sur l'île clairement pas
tu penses quoi je pense qu'il ya des
défrichements
mundo de turtle dans le chat nous d'y
prolonger la vie c'est bien sûr une
statue tout m ce qu'assure en même temps
alors il ya aussi céline qui nous dit
j'ai entendu parler d'un échange de
helton hohmeister noir
j'ai vu de sorte qu'elle va où j'ai vu
aussi cette rumeur
mais je entre deux pivots du moins soft
dont l'un est blessé et l'autre passent
plus de temps sur la playstation que à
s'entraîner
voilà je je sais pas si on est sur du
win-win très honnêtement je pense que ça
serve pas dans la surtout ne débourse
que c'est suppose que ces mix
[Musique]
on et pearl on n'est pas là pour faire
des suppositions parlons de taris -on
ne pas un petit à petit comme ça étonne
il ne devra jamais ne l'aviez pas la
fibre les gars on est
trop facile cette fois je suis désolé
avec les éoliennes ça fournie par le
réseau donc il faut être réaliste ça
n'arrivera pas juste pour ça ça ne
passeront pas la peau dure parce que je
les ai parlé du de son avenir en hôpital
psychiatrique et du prozac et tout ça
mais avant elle à danger dans le jeu
c'est ça même quelque chose bien sûr ça
te fera un partenaire de pick and roll
explosif pour ta usa les bottes c'est un
joueur qui peut coûter des très très bon
écran qui est massif très agressive vers
le cercle qui fait toujours tomber des
fautes s'y est pas un créateur depuis la
ligne à trois points mais chercheurs
troll capable de poser le ballon en main
droite main gauche angers demain un spin
move les épaules bien puissante un
athlète verticale avec une croûte
estompe sèche qui peut qui peut qui peut
punir tu as un joueur tient à tir auquel
on croit pas forcément c'est vraiment
une grosse question de le dire mais qui
a montré un peu tout chez chanteur troll
avec des options qui peut quand même
passer le ballon c'est pas parce qu'il
est fou que le joueur est totalement
buté est une allusion il petit qu'à
l'opposé donc voilà ça peut être un
asiatique fait sur sa première année où
si je vous 20 minutes difficiles faute
comme ceux qui faisaient les sous mais
je vois les vingt minutes qui jouit les
impacts dans un projet de reconstruction
ça peut vraiment une arme et ça peut
donner enfin du de l'espace à tabriz
halliburton et de la polyvalence comme
extérieur j'ai toujours caché derrière
la ligne à 30 ans
j'ai remis les stades pour mettre en
avant une chose on va dire même deux
choses
31% 32% presse d'automne usage ce qu'est
au pour un joueur de son poste qui est
même très haut seulement 14% de ballons
perdus on voit la progression entre
l'anr est l'année de d'ailleurs keno
et vous regardez la colonne ftr le taux
de lancers francs le free trade qui à 51
5 c'est énorme c'est je pense que celui
call plus haut parmi les candidats au
top 10 les trois d'en haut par exemple
ils tournent tous autour de 30 au niveau
du free trade qui est le nombre de
lancers francs tentés divisé par le
nombre de tirs tentés total
fois sens
donc c'est un avantage et il me semble
que c'est quasiment sûr j'ai plus la
stat en tête mais une diana c'est dans
les dix dernières équipes de la ligue en
termes de lancer franc provoqué d'armes
de aller chercher des points sur la
ligne 6 et
finir sur ta reason
ça peut aussi tu parlais du jeu sur demi
terrain mais c'est aussi quelqu'un qui
est capable quand même de prendre 1
rebond partir en transition et donc
d'aller dans cette dans cette identité
dont parlait le chat à leurs deux pays
un peu plus élevé qu on a connaissance
saisonnière on essaye depuis tout à
l'heure je me retiens c'est le nombre de
badges tout l'intérêt que c'est
ce calme un petit peu moi tu vois je
suis un meneur gestionnaire huawei peut
clairement prendre le prendre le prendre
le rebond poser 5 6 dribble être au
panier de monter dessus il a pas peur ça
peut vraiment être avoir lâché les
chevaux avec tara wilson c'est c'est
clairement le l'optique et défensivement
c'était énormément de fautes et ce dans
toutes les fêtes et tout ça il est très
jeune et très très brut c'est vraiment
un brutus mai mais la polyvalence la
puissance du joueur et le fait de
pouvoir défendre vous peut émettre et
sous le panier que c'était là c'est
vraiment hyper excitant
bon il nous reste à parler d'un joueur
dont vous voulez pas parler mais quand
même mais quand même il est vu dans le
top 10 partout il est même vu dans le
top 5 un certain spéciale il s'appelle
tigane nord est ce que je devais m et
là
je crois
qu'ils gagneraient et si nul que ça non
non il est pas nul le joueur 7 c'est
juste que c'est pas top 10 de draft est
cueilli espionne en fait c'est parce
qu'on est dans une mode je pense que tu
es jacques toutes les deux semaines on a
un joueur qui est mis en avant par ea
espionne et la forme en sachant qu'ils
viennent mais je pense que ça peut ça
peut tourner johnny davis l'été avant et
je trouve ça plus justifiée deegan le
west pour le profil temps un ailier
poste 3-4 qui deuxième saison iowa qui a
un frère jumeau
qui a montré des progrès énormes c'est
un très bon tireur notamment leurs pick
and pop c'est pas un mec qui peut créer
ballaman pour moi il ya un manque de
polyvalence défensif parce qu'un manque
de latéralité c'est pas un athlète
verticale être impressionnant donc c'est
pas un joueur qui va pouvoir punir jour
des reversements des cut et être monté
dessus c'est un passeur qui a progressé
c'est un très bon joueur de basket mais
je pense qu'il y aura un rôle limité en
nba qui est celui de poser des écrans
relais pop et et pour moi ça ça vaut pas
un top 6 de draft aussi faible a draft
soit elle
on rappelle aux beats opine l'uia dessus
moulins ont été pris dans le top 10 sur
des profils un peu équivalent mes
hobbies copine était un athlète bien
plus intéressant et un meilleur
dribbleur trouver et lui a dit lula
avait un beau coup plus de jeu le post
bas et beaucoup plus d'eux voilà deux
choses en magasin que keegan mais elles
ne montrent pas est déjà quasiment 22
ans même pour un sofa mort c'est à ces
mêmes
alors même au bill erwin avait pas des
chiffres d'efficacité aussi
impressionnant d'autant plus dans la
mitaine c'est aussi pour ça qu'il est
haut dans les dents dans certaines notes
parce que on sait que demain en billets
il apporte tout de suite une assurance
de je vais scorer je vais m'intégrer
dans son schéma défensif
sur le schéma défensif ddps hers
c'est un profil de quoi de wind stoppeur
c'est pour moi il défendra jamais le
meilleur ailier porteur de balle qui
sera pas mis sur les 200 et tu ne seras
pas méchant ce genre de jour là par
contre il lit bien le jeu j'aime bien
son second rideau donc qui peut être mis
sur le moins bon porteur de balle ailier
mais faire des très bonnes rotations
venir compenser sous le cercle et c'est
donc voilà c'est un joueur qui fait très
payante à ceske collectif tout ça mais
c'est un joueur de plus comme ça dans
une équipe qui en a déjà plein si
l'épaisseur zh récupère un second choix
dans ce top 20 de ce top 15 très bien
très très bien pas de reconstruction
c'est un joueur qui va t'apporter mais
tu utilises pas là-dessus disparaît
dessus dans ton projet si tu dois
vraiment repartir depuis le début
dans le profil melvin un joueur qui va
apporter vite
on prévoit aussi que la draf 2023
il y aura des joueurs bien plus
impactant sur le haut est ce que ça vaut
pas le coup de draft est un mec
finalement
pas mal et dont on est sûr du plancher
et de prendre son ticket pour la
superstar l'année prochaine
j'ai envie de dire c'est un pari après
moi je reviens encore oh
ça veut dire à la situation actuelle des
épaisseurs cgg pas toujours du mal à
penser que leur écart là il va
tranquillement mené une équipe à vingt
victoires la nef de la saison prochaine
donc bon et on sait que bon reconstruire
ça peut prendre du temps
il n'y a aucune assurance qui prendra
fin dans le top 5 l'année prochaine non
plus donc il n'y a traité plus de plus
de stars l'année prochaine mais ça reste
quand même assez risqué donc moi je moi
ça me fait un peu peur de prendre
quelqu'un qui pense que ce que dit luxe
et c'est pas quelqu'un qui m'a vraiment
faire la différence oui va pouvoir
apporter mais c'est pas le c'est pas le
mec il a rarement de faire passer à un
niveau vraiment même faire encore la
salle je pense du côté des médias là
donc
moi je vais me ranger dans le camp
demain je pense que je vais pas être
trop pas non plus de ceux qui
l'ignoraient pour les pour les pc
offre qu'il ya une personne n'en veut
mais c'est bien finira bien par avoir
moi je le veux bien chez moi chicago mai
au 18 voilà très tragique un
score la ducasse de qui n'a t'on pas
parler ugl danser au large hollande
ghalem durel j'ai volontairement exclus
parce que je parce que je suis fan
d'alsace jackson et que j'ai pas envie
c'est un choix dicté par
un stage de 10
il reste johnny davis
par le johnny davis comment alors un
profil deux trois gros moteur
comment ils savent comment ils
s'insèrent auprès de d'halliburton
est-ce que qu'est-ce qui peut être se s
qui peut être c'est une bonne question
ce stoppeur défensif qui met de
l'énergie ont pour un peu entraîné toute
l'équipe avec une essence ouais il peut
il peut alors jonny bellis c'est un
joueur pareil sauf mort qu'il fait une
grosse saison du côté louise comme s'ils
n'étaient pas attendus faut être honnête
on a fait un article où on parlait des
joueurs qui pourraient exploser
deschamps ce poste-là
on l'avait pas vu venir en tout cas
personnellement j'avais pas vu venir et
allen avec qui on a vécu le truc non
plus c'est un joueur qui pour le coup
elle n'a amène le fait qu'ils puissent
créer son propre tir il a émis des bons
pull-ups il avait aussi dans
l'habituelle conférence compliqué
toujours mis sur enfin toujours
défendues par le meilleur défenseur
opposé il l'a toujours détruits soit
parce que son driver trop efficace pour
les jours tant qu'e soit parce qu'il est
trop grand et déjà puissant pour les
joueurs plus petits
je trouve sa défense est intéressante
mais peut-être plus grands moi je le
vois bien défendre plus grand que 2/3
+34 tu vois j'ai un rêve pour moi j'ai
un développement interne pour le joueur
où on va essayer de maximiser la
puissance et on va turin profil plus
crise middleton dans le dans le genre ah
qu'il est un peu comparé que des vignes
booker à qui il est aussi beaucoup
comparé par par mike schmidt quand ma
cuisse le voyait lui a fait la
comparaison il ya de ça aussi ça peut
vraiment être un profil comme ça et en
plus il n'attire extérieur pour pouvoir
effectivement vivre à l'opposé quand
elle halliburton a le ballon voire même
lui poser des écrans il l'a fait un peu
house comme si
effectivement johnattan davis une
progression impressionnants je vous mets
les stats passe de 7 points à 20 points
par match
en deuxième année
il avait joué avec team usa pro tour aux
fameuses de finale contre la france en
et donc un joueur effectivement comme
disait lucas qui a eu un gros rôle
offensif mans 32 5 % d'usagers de poté
seront utilisés par l'udc dans au sein
de son équipe est pareil quant aux deux
lancers francs intéressants qui frôle
les 40 un joueur qui est qui a dominé
physiquement ça veut dire ça en les
joueurs qui se créent des lancers francs
c'est des joueurs qui domine
physiquement
l'espace wilson t'arrive eason est un
phénomène physique il plus de 50 je vais
thème d ici à 40 c'est quand même un
joueur qui était dans une conférence
très compliqué qui a qui a effectivement
su dominer alors avec une efficacité
plus ou moins grande c'est pas le fg est
pas
mais il sait créer l'élan s'est
cependant ce
signe comme ça qu'on voit trop tard pour
103 pompiers pas ouf mais il ya 40% qui
sont créés en couleur ce qui est déjà
très conséquent au niveau n'diaye et on
est à 30 5% sur les deux points non
médias que en gros 92% des deux points
qui l'a pris c'est du poulet donc c'est
un joueur qui a énormément créé balle en
main avec aucun de créateurs à ses côtés
et donc ça explique aussi que il n'
efficacité plus basses par rapport à des
mecs qui avaient des meilleurs systèmes
autour de plus de joueurs polyvalents
plus de menaces bénédicte mathurin qui
est souvent cité dans ses alentours la
lui il a vraiment tout fait par lui même
oui les citer aussi par le chat par
djibo emmanuel qui me dit bénédicte
nature juste sans explication du bénin
nature
melvin sur le profil johnny davis
qu'est-ce que tu es content dit sur le
papier sur le comment tu imagines ça
ouais sur le papier alors
gelé absolument pas joué cette année
donc je
vois les jeux boit les paroles du gain
et sur les paroles du gct j'aime
beaucoup profil parce que je pense que
tu peux avoir
cet aspect physique cet aspect défensif
dont on a parlé mais aussi d'avoir ce
potentiel offensif que ce soit au niveau
du tier 1 au niveau de la création
donc je suis là j'ai pas vu il a quel
âge
il ya eu d'intenses les 1/2 de savourer
ce faubourg ouais donc donc j'aime bien
parce que ce moment le je pense le
joueur que tu peux que tu peux
développer
selon ce dont on a besoin à côté d'un
côté de la libertad par exemple
donc j'ai envie de dire ils
quittent chaque toutes les casinos
étaient toutes les boîtes quoi les box
et
les expressions
franco-américaine blizzard a raison de
me répéter il faut qu'on vient san
francisco il faut tu dois pas mort
je vais faire le l'avocat de bénédicte
mathurin du cul des plus johnny que ben
et moi plutôt l inverse même si j'aime
beaucoup ne se donne même tiers chez moi
bénédicte mathurin est un score
vraiment micron qui a eu pour le conduit
un shoot fiable jour un nba alors que
johnny davis a encore peut-être plus de
questions - de moins d'impact physique
vers le cercle même si là il a lui aussi
su aller
sur la ligne des lancers francs mais
avec dans un contexte d' équipe beaucoup
plus facile que celui qui a connu deux
jeunes idée vis à vis comme si bénédicte
mathurin jouets et de qui est québécois
y parle français
jouent à arizona dans une équipe très
internationale un basket très agréable à
voir jouer
cette année
un camerounais en pivot un estonien à la
mène
c'est elle à l'auberge espagnole donc un
isolat et bénédicte natura a posté des
gros des gros pourcentages une grosse
efficacité au scoring une capacité à
être plus efficaces dans les gros matchs
que dans les autres matches importants
et simplement peut-être moins de
potentiel que johnny davis a juste lui
créer pour les autres
il peut il peut se créer son tir ne va
pas forcément faire d'écart mais
il a peu joué de pick and roll ce parce
qu'on lui demandait
mais mais mais sur le les basses fins
non passeur cinq rockeurs
mais c'est pas sa force principale et
c'est pas ce qu'on lui demandera sans
doute en année avec ces deux profils
répondant à la question de p g 26 69
est-ce qu'on est plus mature 1 ou johnny
davis marne dans l'idée
dans l'idée vu comme on nous l'a vendu
avec johnny davis a l'air plus
intéressant il ya de quoi développer
aussi
mois pour le coup tu avais une petite
interrogation entre les deux jeux ça que
mathurin j'ai pu voir je vois revenir
ceux de temps en temps quand même en six
mois que joey davis jusqu'ici je n'avais
pas vu pas trouvé venir
lequel des deux serait le plus slasher
potentiellement
du beau johnny c'est assez largement
malgré l'impact comme ça il y va quand
c'est ouvert ça l'athlète bien plus
intéressant verticalement il a un vrai
flotteurs et si le le déclic mental de
dire je peux aller au sac je peut me
rentrer dans les autres parce c'est un
potentiel bien plus élevé ça peut être
bien meilleur slasher à terme mais moi
psychologiquement il n'aime pas trop ça
pour l'instant effectif il a en fait il
a dominé y aller sur la ligne parce que
comme dit il et il est dominant
physiquement il est là on premiers pas
pu plus rapide que la moyenne et ancien
il a les deux pieds sur la tête de
pardon
d'aller des systèmes arizona où sortait
d'un écran les systèmes touche ligne de
fond mais c'est lui qui a calé au alley
oops
voilà c'est ce genre d'athlète la vie
johnny davis est aussi mais moi qui ont
poussé un athlète dans la puissance
quand est ce que dans l'explosivité
et hugh m la puissance moi j'aime
l'explosivité
ce que j'en ai pas de gérer posthumes du
roi
grenouille lorsqu'il dit la foule qui
hurle comme johnny après un gros dunk
j'aurai mes arguments nous avons
[Rires]
effectivement
ça se joue à peu de choses
parfois un choix de un choix de draft
est-ce que tu as entendu parler d'autres
d'autres personnes marins ne votez juste
pas dé voir car des rumeurs d'intérêt
n'ont jusqu'ici en tout cas pour le pixi
c'est vraiment tout ce que j'ai pu voir
passer
c'est que apparemment avec bénédicte
mathurin a l'air d'être suffisamment
voyez souvent on revient souvent il a
l'air de bien revenir et ça c'est plus
haut par lesbiennes et athlétique et
c'est dans les mots qui font même john
john attah nwaas herman qui
donc repris par le site de la nba et
mais mature un plus haut avec des
probabilités plus importante de draft et
top 10 que johnny davis qui serait plus
sans de loterie selon les rapports mais
après est un empêche indiana de tomber
amoureux voyez
je vais voir la question de feeling
aussi non pour le coup j'ai pas vu
d'autres prétendants qui revenait très
sérieusement
et au delà la propagande genii vie dans
les mentions qui malheureusement qui
fait son effet mais malheureusement on
verra on verra où ça c'est pas exclu il
ya un scénario qui existe avec avec
sharp qui parle en deux et après tout
pas en quoi
c'est possible c'est possible
imagine que des trois tombe amoureux de
je ne sais pas qui en ce1
se seraient donné
sa news étonnamment
rondot qui demande johnny davis peut-il
jouer en trois pourvois il doit de même
joué en 3 fat il doit jouer ailier pour
moi et toi tu attaques et des ailiers
même si l'attaquant sanctions amplement
une pièce qui tu attaques parce que
voilà mes parent continue pour moi il
sera mieux sur la défense des ailiers
voilà je le vois là - voilà sur un bac
courte avec tel vous halliburton n'est
plus sur un poste 3-4
on a notre spécialiste wes cause qu'ils
défendent
bénédicte mathurin 10 pour la fin
d'année dans les matches le match perdu
contre houston c'est à la march madness
ou pas dit il est très agressif et c'est
vrai que ben mathurin mais comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure dans les moments
importants il a su faire preuve de
caractère
et ils veulent ils aiment là il avait
beaucoup de confiance en lui le jour
pour le coup tu vois il a fait les
interviews like mike smith il est arrivé
sapé comme jamais
il voulait vraiment il était là beau
gosse hyper asymétrique y regarder la
caméra et regardez jamais son
interlocuteur il dit ouais moi je suis
meilleur et tous et nous voilà tu as
envie de le croire c'est un mec vraiment
très sage tu vas sa starification et ils
se voient très très beaux prés il est
très très beau vendent ils se voient
très très
belle ouais c'est récemment des maillots
un savant tu vois toujours les grandes
affiches dantesque dieu j'ai pas vous
avez quoi comme salon de l'agriculture
le mammouth il ya la police tu vois me
battre at ça vient et ben tu peux le
mettre en grand à mettre 80 sur 1 mètre
une question tourne aylwin
dirais comme ça il ya les pics 31 et 58
du coup du côté de diana
je te demande évidemment pas des noms
mais je te demande un profil selon toi
quel genre de profil on doit aller
target généralement dans ces eaux là y'a
ur du potentiel cloud et andy ou du
meneur backup ou d'urines runner en gros
et après il ya des gens flou genre kerry
taylor on sait pas mettre dans une case
médicaux bd une équipe bien ouais
je trouve qu'ils sont pas mal de fin de
la déjà dit je pense de joueurs qui ont
qui vont être des bons rôles players
du coup je dirais peut-être
j'ai envie de dire rim runner parce
qu'on a notre ami mike turner qui aime
une cam tellement juste rester derrière
en point que ça pourrait être un peu
complémentaire a dit à jackson était un
peu dans ce rôle peut-être un petit peu
un petit peu petit donc pourquoi pas ça
et puis après est-ce qu'il ya dsk ddd
des prospects internationaux qui peuvent
un peu de pour les draft aimé les garder
à l'égard des que ce soit en europe ou
ailleurs pendant quelques années qui
pourrait intéresser les épaisseurs selon
vous
d'abord je pose la même question à
marans qu'elle quel genre de profil et
après on essaie de répondre avec google
suis je suis relativement d'accord avec
les profils
surtout voilà surtout en 31 58 faut
vraiment tenter des choses voilà mise et
les grosses cotes les gros potentiel et
loire voilà des diamant à polir des gens
un peu brut de décoffrage comme ça bon
j'ai pas d'immense nom en tête je sais
pas si nicolas hulot vite 131 c'est
plausible ou non ça et que ça me plaît
bien sur le papier maintenant à voir
j'ai pas trop regarder plus que c'est à
part ça mais voilà tout miser sur
l'avenir et le talent aussi
c'est sur mais bon ma foi je sais pas
faux pour moi c'est du potentiel
c'est un très bon joueur moi je pensais
partir avant je connais très bien mais
il a très bien mesuré ouais moi aussi je
vais le voter il a très bien mesurer au
combat il est il ya quasiment ils
admettront
toute image qu'à 35% c'est sûr à trois
points il est capable de lire un clause
à août et de poser la balle au sol et
sur la bonne parce qu'il faut après
c'est un joueur c'est un bon joueur à à
utiliser en pick and go home a minima et
peut-être plus s'ils arrivent à courir
autour des écrans étaient d'accord ouais
totalement c'est un vrai bon quatre
machines avec de la vision et tout est
très excitant alors regardez le cac à
mes gars je sais pas quoi ça change tous
les temps non les gardoises art mega
mozart fait insupportable et balou et
son rose bleu avec les numéros star game
à savoir autant sur le terrain tout est
joyeux youtube c'est horrible a fermé le
jour et qui font leur agrément qui
change alors notre b g 26 69 qui dit on
veut un talent et norton de coeur ou bee
gees boston quel genre de profil que
glisser moi j'ai un nom jean montéro
ali petit moteur
jean gontéro il n'a pas très bien mesuré
c'est un joueur qui était en overtime
élite
c'est pour ceux qui nous connaissent pas
la ligue de
développement des lycéens qui a été
créée en fait au lieu d'aller au lycée
ils vont ici
ils sont payés c'est la grande
différence
est là le problème pour l'évaluation
pour nous c'était que c'est une île où
il y avait des joueurs contre 16 et 18
ans c'est à dire qu'à 16 ans évidemment
que physiquement on n'est pas le mec
excitant encore plus que la différence
était encore plus criante que pour
évaluer des joueurs initiés
et monteiro et aidant les plus vieux il
a évidemment dominée maintenant monteiro
c'est quelqu'un qui a un des meilleurs
randle de de cette cuvée de draft c'est
un honneur qui va donc dans la raquette
très facilement ok malheureusement très
léger
fait ses mensurations tout à l'heure
j'ai actualisé avec le combat et je
crois qu'il dépasse difficilement les 75
kg et
pour pour 1 m 85 88
c'est pas de chaque bloc lance
une opa de jeanne beker mais bon mais
c'est comme comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure avec mathurin c'est un joueur
avec une confiance en lui qui est assez
impressionnante qui se comportent tout
le temps comme s'il était le meilleur
joueur sur le terrain
et pour le coup je lui pense que la
complémentarité avec halliburton est pas
et pas déconnante même s'il met les deux
sur un bac courte nouveau de
l'efficacité des 106
mm ses commentaires ses nombreux si je
l' ai mis tout à l'heure dans la fiche
yoga on a cité son nom
maintenant on n'a pas cité son nom mais
il était dans le lidl dans le roster
quotidien
il fait pas partie de l'historique de
draft favorable
et par an kwh de 18 ans à 18,9 google
ouais après ces deux cd avant jc
d'esrange difficile à
utah d'autres candidats de joueur qui
était vue très beau et qui peuvent
glisser voilà en 31 parce que sa
conduite c'est bon ça il disait des
prospections raté leur saison
il ya un mec qui fêterait nyala c'est
patrick baldwin junior qui peut être
glissé qui a une vraiment pour le goûter
à une cote n'a fait que chuter depuis le
début d'année qui était un temps du top
10 excellent gros tireur qui joue à
milwaukee dans une toute petite fac
côtier pour son papa et qui a montré que
athlétiquement parlant c'était horrible
c'était vraiment pas bons partis
calmement dans la campagne et paniers
latéralement mais qu'il ya un tir à
trois points excellent exceptionnel
vraiment un bon plus défensif un bon
passeur qui fait des mesures puis au
combat il ça peut être un jour tu peux
aller choper là-dessus petit peut être
un spécialiste à trois points à terme tu
vois tu veux pas prendre qui gagnent le
web a peut-être que tu paies c'est
d'abord à peu près la même chose avec
patrick baldwin et il y aura plusieurs
contres en nba c'est sûr c'est sur ce
genre du pit yens pop pure et autres
prospects qui a raté son année et tony
watson grosse énigme yves si elle est
ailier pour le coup procureur profil
défensif très intrigant on sait pas s'il
va râler en billets mais voilà il a
refusé aux compagnes participer au mode
55 donc c'est vraiment que lui joue
toujours le mystère on l'appelle martin
dans le milieu et on va vous qui la
prononce ouais et c'est très tôt très
très très tôt mais c'est possible oui
oui et donc voilà peyton watson on sait
qu'on ne sait rien il faut remonter au
lycée et ça peut être c'est plus d'une
grosse cote toit au-dessus
des mois on sait qui switch qui switch
2-3-4 assez facilement un millier à mon
avis
je suis un joueur qui est vraiment très
long
et qui a montré par flash il avait peu
de temps jeu à lui si elle aime et que
tu vois là ils l'avaient
huawei continue et c'est ainsi qu'ils
pouvaient rentrer dès qu'ils pouvaient
rentrer ces tirs ou d'un côté on a un
intrus yens au
avait compris que baldwin de l'autre
côté on a on a un om dit avec avec
peyton watson option fait
on a un profil si c'est aubry à des
pierres visage de ce mélange qui est
deux à lobito ne avec les baguettes tout
ça tu vends rien tu vaux rien en terme
de marketing mais le joueur de basket
est intéressant
et pour répondre à la question de
mézilles sont les internationaux
les internationaux sont surtout des
français
autour alors appris que y avoir du
joueur intérieur avec enzo zaveck
khalifa diop qui sont candidats donc
c'est que des deux pivots n2a plus
hyper
difficile à gérer on va dire à il faut
lui apprendre les rotations quoi mais
par contre un profil physique fou aux
bêtes m'en fous avec une envergure de
malades et une mobilité a pas normal
pour sa taille vraiment très très mobile
et khalifa d'york plus près du sol mais
en progression constante on avait tous
n'en a parlé déjà l'année dernière
vous pouvez remonter un podcast de
l'année dernière
où déjà il y avait une vraie progression
sur la vision de jeu sur le short roll
ce genre de chose qui ait demandé un
pivot nba aujourd'hui donc il ya ce
genre de profil acquis après il ya les
gober son
côté français qui peut faire office un
profil qui est pas trop lâches et
indiana marins de degas de qu'arrive de
la seconde unité qui font un peu le feu
quoi qui cale droite quel droit
dédicacer sa jordan clarkson en gros un
peu en roue libre ont sorti le mans se
serait ce sera un vrai plus en plus je
croque iep il monte un peu google sont
en ce moment
donc je dis moi j'ai pas aimé janvier
oui bah ça c'est sûr que c'est un
jouteur le hibou badge il dit pierre
aussi en terme de grands il me semble
qu'il est candidat aussi
hugo besson et on aura
potentiellement effectivement kamagaté
même s'il peut partir au premier tour
une seringue et magath est peut être là
qui est un grand aussi alors
moi je trouve qu'il ya déjà ce qu'il
faut en terme de grands indiana mais
mais mais c'est vrai qu'il a qui aiment
bien s'écarter
genre meistermann
après ben pour le coup petter hansson
c'était ça le jour du ciel et
voilà j'ai un peu peur il ya
jurisprudence
petite jennifer renault leader
elle aime beaucoup ucla mais c'est alors
il y aurait du meilleur mais bon il sait
pas c'est pas une diana qui dresse haïk
annick beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà voilà c'est vrai que la filière
l'autoroute los angeles
laisse des traces
bienvenue à logan qui nous dit possible
qui est un joueur alors
c'est qui c'est raphaël barlow qui est
ce qu'à un journaliste qui couvre la
drac
qui qui est au combat et qui dit que sa
cote monte un petit peu chez les exactes
nba
je lui ai demandé avec le concile avait
musclé son jeu gaby parce que parce
qu'effectivement c'est un joueur super
mécanique de tir les grands essais deux
sets de 6-2
7-6 là pas peur de te tirer
voilà une sorte
de nakiele le comparer à bogdanovic
c'est un petit peu ambitieux mais mais
voilà dans le style gars qui vient
d'europe qui s'étire et qui a pas peur
qu'à accepter de plus être une star
qu'il était quand il était dans les
équipes jeunes évidemment
voilà qui a accepté son rôle de jeu
j'arrive et je dois rentrer des shoots
et je dois défendre le problème ce sera
le premier aussi la la défense dans le
chat qui en train de péter un plomb loin
parce que j'ai l'impression que je tape
tous les mecs de sa conférence de la pac
n'est pas vrai je ne vis pas bien de
deux mecs avant payton watson à la halle
avantage pour new style et c'est que si
vous ratez les mecs qui ont passé pardus
il est je pense que peyton watson a
détesté du cil et peut-être que ça peut
faire l'effet inverse et ça peut marcher
ça peut marcher
exactement le mc dermott un peu pour
rossi cas
une bonne comparaison m6 mcdermott plus
+ tank est plus près du sol au sida
m'inquiète un peu plus irene
1h30 qu'on est là à parler d'épaisseur
ça file marc est ce que tu as une autre
question melvin aussi où est ce qu'on va
où est-ce qu'on referme ce prêt de racht
all she numéro 10 de mon côté pas
d'autres questions on prépare les cers
pour j'étais naïve et
moi j'ai une quête moi j'ai une question
c'est vrai qu'au début on entend parler
de la stratégie de badra pour
l'épaisseur on avait dix
meilleurs joueurs disponibles en 6 donc
si on se dit que le top 4 il est top 4
eglessies griffin 45 pour ou pour toi
hughes est pour toi alex qui serait le
meilleur joueur disponible à ce moment
là pour les dp ça
prend le temps de réfléchir moi chat non
chargées anglais et pour l'huile déjà
porté chance non
le top le top 4 pour vous c'est quoi
c'est donc on a quatre paulo des dames
arrivée à paris le top 4 consensus c'est
ça ouais tchèque paulo ivy et semi
imaginons griffin partagé 3 bout ça
pour moi c'est chaque mois charge les en
deux sur mon mais j'ai pas vu beaucoup
de matches comme tout le monde quoi mais
juste dans une draft qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de
talent fou lui il a un talent fou avec
énormément de risques donc
j'y vais j'y vais
je sais qu'en plus je serai pas bon
l'année prochaine je vais changer
brockton prendre des gros contrats pour
prendre des futurs pic
baudile pareil s'il faut
je sais pas avec qui mais voilà plus que
prendre des pics
cette année ou alors prendre un pic
voilà dans les vins etc pour tenter
aussi un coup sûr en notre potentiel
genre de choses et
ouais drafté chez dolce à être mauvais
l'année qui arrive tranquillement et
aller à la draf 2023 avec avec la
volonté
d'être au moins dans le top 5 si tu as
un des trois plus mauvais bilan tu peux
pas tomber en dessous du top 6 et pour
le moment il ya un top 7 6 est vraiment
très très solide qui se dégage en 2023
avec des joueurs à plus ou moins de
risque effectivement mais on à victor
hanescu tombeur sache qu'on allait
jumeau tom trust et et on a des joueurs
qui vont sortir de l ancien qui seront
très forts moi j'ai dernier quoi éviter
donc peut-être de manière qui n'a
d'autre sinon ils seront là plus des
jaden albi qui vont exploser alors
saison fraîche même si
il y aura ce sera un peu plus dense sur
l'eau de la draft au moins donc qu'on
change
1,6
je fais pareil c# il est dispo je prends
je crois la paternité la famille
sinon membres à 0 3 me après 6,6 sharp
il est pas là et que les jack griffin
qui est là et que tu veux vraiment
reconstruire donc les gens ont du talent
moi je m' insiste benjamin tiens je
prends des 26 bonnes parce que je veux
le meilleur cadre possible franchement
honnêtement parlant à l'accent si je
peux très d'emma cameron pour avoir un
petit con un pic 12 13 et où mike turner
et à tous il faudrait à ce moment là des
mecs comme qui gagnerait tout je
prendrai des jours cf mais je prends le
pour moi le plus gros talent balle en
main le potentiel all star que j'ai
c'est le mec que je suis on le calcule
plus sûr là dessus voilà juste la
dernière 22 ans joue il a 22 ans joue
pas il n'a pas besoin il fait 2 m 01 ils
m'ont toujours tout le monde il a marqué
39 points 52 milteau combined 39 points
sa conduite le monde lui a dit chante
pas il a dit je m'en fous je mets 39
points
et au dernier vingt odile 60 % aux tirs
attention ça vaut rien
il a brossé une chaise
ouais voilà c'est un peu les options
kiala et après moi derrière ce top 6
donc j'ai recueilli griffin et écharpe
moi j'aime à turin derrière qui selon
moi s'il passe ce cap
en fait il a un plancher sur parce qu'il
est fort aux shoots et que c'est un
défenseur correct et il a
potentiellement un plafond devrait
scoreur
j'ai pas de comparaison en tête mais
voilà un vrai scoreur qui va mettre sa
taille leur héros
tyler héros qui défendrait
le plafond voilà donc la priorité de
marins et de mails digne c'est jason a
dit y'a pas de zielona il dit nous on a
dit avec lui chez danemark où est jean
guy finn et si les trois sont pas là ça
veut dire qu'il y en a des
trois gros qui qui sera là donc 10
mythes baume quéro où le combat je le
mans pas où du coup ça va sûrement fait
comme l'émir un petit peu au local
sellers je prend avec plaisir
à base ccb notre notre site idéal pour
paulo
moi j'avais besoin d'être impressionné
par par par l'eau pendant le rendement
est fier notamment pas on sait le talent
qu'il a mais j'avais été elle est
impressionnée par la son calme j'ai
trouvé vachement
weasley vachement mature pour son âge
il est il est effectivement très
n'est pas dans l'émotion quand il est
sur le terrain il est vraiment dans la
détermination de phishing
et ça irait très bien s'il apprend
imposer des écrans devraient pouvoir
certes
avec halliburton ça peux
tu feras mahmoud ben ali comme marin
quand une équipe se fera d'être probants
de kerho tu pourras d'ignorer ce que tu
aurais pu avoir ça
c'est ça tu profiteras comme ça tu
joueras tout que tu feras être à aider
ça ira ça je vous ferai des balles de
ping pong et voilà quoi
melvin est ce que on peut faire une
promo pour toi est ce que tu as des
contenus qui sortent ouais bah écoutez
moi je moi basket usa je couvre
principalement les warriors soir sur le
rôle que je suis sur place et du coup
j'ai des articles qui charte après tous
les matches la preuve aux play-offs le
dernier en date qui était plus sur le
sur le tir à trois points des matches
comme comme étant la roulette russe si
ça marche c'est très bien quand ça veut
pas rentrer c'est c'est pire donc
l'histoire des deux mi-temps dire
exactement le cas ça et puis après tout
les leur choix qu'en france et tous les
mercredis je suis sur sport en france
avec la team ait on essaye de l'éduquer
impôts les gens sur le basket mais aussi
de de faire des analyses donc si vous
avez peu l'utl si vous n'avez pas eu
encore le l'option de regarder ça allait
aller sur sport en france où aller sur
la chaîne youtube de hype il ya tout les
atouts de la route
effectivement
intéressant marins ce que vous avez des
contenus chez pays sears et faire a batu
jour on est là on va sur la
reconstruction comme il se doit
personnellement je suis très excité ça
change voilà l'autriche n'avait pas
connu ça depuis j'ai pas connu ça en
fait tout simplement de pigeons et en
sucre le comte existe là bas voilà c'est
comme ça
donc ouais très excité on va essayer de
suivre ça de très près et ont hâte de
voir ça fini le ventre mou et les forces
de vente d'exceet on reconstruit les
choses calmement je l'espère on va
suivre ça grand intérêt toujours sur
twitter on sera on sera toujours là
vendée
a bien eus on se retrouve très bientôt
pour sautois tu es là tous les vendredis
soirs sur twitch mais il ya aussi
d'autres live à venir le prochain c'est
dans deux jours et on va parler des
roquettes sud et pistol je me rappelle
plus des roquettes choix
requête
le 23 donc les roquettes ça avec un pic
quatre mains aussi indiqué ce que je
raconte trois
très très intéressant tous dans le tchat
merci ice rabbit d'avoir fait une petite
référence à la victoire qui vient de se
dérouler de l'anatolie et fès face au
real madrid en finale de l'euroligue
doublé pour beaubois et moerman bravo à
eux et merci à toi maman merci à toi
melting une dernière question
est-ce que tu auras dans deux jours le
maillot de l'as dit peau des roquettes
ou pas sur le lag non non non non
malheureusement non je crois je suis
même nom je suis pas là dans deux jours
mais on se revoit pour trouva pour les
kings pour moi et je n'aurai aucun
maillot pour les kicks mais beaucoup
médicaments parce que j'ai beaucoup de
tendresse pauvres
effectivement ça arrive c'est sale dans
deux jours ce sera belle à la place de
hugo à l'analyse c'est plus mature plus
de jours dans la voix c'est bien plus
intéressant à écouter
bmx en taxant
québécois pour parler de tête de
belgique matures sinon pour les autres
c'est ce fameux
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis
pendant ce live on vous fait des gros
bisous et on se retrouve très bientôt
aller voir sur notre sur notre chaîne
youtube sur notre site en dernier on
pensait au plein de contenus plein de
scouting report tous les joueurs
desquels on a parlé aujourd'hui on leur
scouting report donc on vous en a montré
deux trois mais vous pouvez aller
naviguer très facilement et vous
renseigner sur les prospects cette cuvée
merci